would i be correct in assuming that when
you speak of anxiety you don't think of
it as a symptom to be removed
but rather as a gateway for exploration
into the meaning of life yes well you
got that exactly right
i think anxiety is associated with
creativity
when you're in a situation of anxiety
you can of course run away from it
and that's certainly not constructive or
you can take a few pills to get you over
it or
cocaine or whatever else you may take
you could meditate
whether you could meditate but i think
none of those things including
meditation which i happen to believe in
but none of those paths leads you to
creative activity what anxiety means
is it's as though the world is knocking
at your door
and you need to create you need to make
something you need to do something
and i think anxiety thus is
when for people who are uh
who have found their own heart and their
own souls
for them it is a stimulus stored toward
creativity
toward courage is what makes us human
beings
i suppose much of our anxiety comes from
the basic human dilemma of being mortal
of
ultimately having to confront our own
demise
we are conscious of our own selves our
own tasks
and also we know we're going to die man
is the only creature men women and
children sometimes even are the only
creatures
who can be aware of their death and out
of that comes normal anxiety
when i let myself feel that then i
apply myself to new ideas i write books
i communicate with my fellows
and in other words the creative
interchange of
human personality rests upon the fact
that we know we're going to die
of that the animals in the grass and so
on knows nothing
but our knowledge of our death is what
gives us
a normal anxiety that says to us make
the most
of these of these years you are alive
and that's what i've tried to do
another source of anxiety that you've
described in your writing is
is our very freedom our ability to make
choices and to have to confront the
consequences of those choices yes that's
right
freedom is the also the
mother of anxiety if you had no freedom
you'd have no anxiety
that's why the slaves in the films
are people without any expression on
their faces
they have no freedom but those of us who
do have
are alert alive we're aware that what we
do
matters and that we only have about
70 or 80 or 90 years in which to do it
so why not do it and get joy out of it
rather than running away from
it i think that's a little capsule
of the meaning of anxiety but isn't
there
a little bit of a a conflict between
feeling anxiety and allowing oneself to
be open vulnerable to that feeling of
anxiety and then also seeking joy
oh no there's a conflict between that
and what's generally called happiness
or the the flat i would speak of of the
meaningless forms
of feeling good i'm not against anybody
feeling good or having
happy hours but joy is something
different from that
joy is the zest that you get out of
using your talents your understanding
your the totality of your being
for great ames the musicians
the men who wrote music mozart and
beethoven and the rest of them they
always
showed considerable anxiety because they
were in the process of
loving beauty of
feeling joy when they heard a beautiful
combination of notes now that's the kind
of
feeling that goes with creativity
that's why i say the courage to create
creation does not come out of
simply what you're born with that must
be united with your courage
which both both of which cause anxiety
but also great joy
it seems that uh much of our modern
culture though is an attempt
to cope with this fundamental anxiety by
diversions and what you've call banal
pleasures
yeah well you just put your finger on
the most significant aspect of
modern society and we try to
avoid anxiety by getting rich
by making a hundred thousand dollars
when we're
21 years of age by becoming millionaires
now none of those things uh lead
to the joy the creativity that i'm
talking about
one can own the world and still
be without the inner sense of
of pleasure of joy of courage of
creation